we're back now talking about the stark
divides in the way black and white
Americans perceived racism even as the
national dialogue about race intensifies
when it comes to applying for a job for
example one poll said 67 percent of
white Americans believe black applicants
have the very same chances only thirty
percent of black adults agree with that
statement the results of that disconnect
and many others is a crisis of
inequality that many white Americans
still struggle to describe amid our
national conversation about racism we
decided to start a few local ones on the
streets of Stanford Connecticut
we asked white Americans some basic
questions about how to treat people of a
different race
I don't remember conversations at home
it just didn't happen you look at the
person not the color of their skin
sometimes fielded questions of our own
do you think you've benefited by being
white in America of course do you within
showed clips of our interactions to
Boston University professor Abram X Ken
D the CBS News contributor and author of
the bestseller how to be an anti-racist
helped us pick out patterns how do you
define racism when one person feels that
they're better than another person what
is a racist then a racist is someone
being discriminatory against somebody
against somebody else's race were you
surprised by those answers oh not in the
least bit
Americans are taught that a racist is an
evil horrible bad person that it's in
someone's bones that someone literally
is a racist that's their identity and so
that's not me I'm a good person
sometimes our conversation started out
easy how do you define racism racism is
is the unjust treatment of people of a
different color national origin that is
either from face-to-face interaction but
also more importantly institutionalized
and yet things could quickly grow
uncomfortable you define racism the way
you did do you fit in that definition in
any way I'm not right
I don't pull those views and no nor
associate with people who do most people
struggle to explain racial inequality
for the typical black family in America
has much less money than the typical
white family how do you explain that
some of it is opportunity some of it is
what is some of it your drive some of
it's the way you're brought up but
there's a lot of black people that don't
get to where they can get I don't know
you know intelligence wise if they're
not as intelligent as white people I
mean there are a lot that are very
intelligent and almost no one used the
term racism the term you're
uncomfortable with the term in some ways
I am yeah I think what's striking is
racist has almost become like the n-word
it's like the R word in which so many
Americans think in and of itself it's
it's a bad word to say when indeed it's
a descriptive term it's a term candy
says that could be applied to just about
anyone at times people can have a racist
thought for example but that doesn't
mean they are racist yeah a racist isn't
an identity it is not who a person is
it's what a person is being and I think
we have to recognize that people hold
both racist and anti-racist ideas and
people are deeply contradictory and in
this moment of national reflection we
did find some Americans trying to iron
out those contradictions in society and
in themselves I do believe in the
systemic racism that we have in America
so as a white person I would say of
course I probably do play a part in that
racism
technically although right I would never
just say I'm racist and I hate people
based on the color of their skin of
course I would not want to do that but I
also think it's misleading when people
say I don't see color you have to see
color you have to respect the
differences you have to understand
different cultures in order to grow out
of the racism that you've been taught so
there's a lot there guys one thing that
leaps out to me is just that you know
when you define racism as something
between people you leave out Society and
if we leave out Society we're never
gonna change it Gael yes I have to say
Tony I lost my hearing after that one
woman said well there are some of them
that are intelligent but what I like
Anthony is that a white person white
Tony Tecopa
is talking to other white people because
I think of a black person had tried to
do that it makes people even more
defensive and they think it's
confrontational these conversations are
so important and it's very important for
white people to ask each other these
questions right now the whole issue of
racism in that word has white people
have a very hard time with it they don't
understand that as Tony pointed out yes
yeah I hate colorblind because of course
you see color
I'd say color brave or be color
conscious but I hate colorblind no it's
very well done Tony tacomas indeed